so we have a new supreme court justice
amy
comey it's a hard name to say i'm going
to
a acb and we're going to get it done
okay
she is uh making it almost a completely
catholic court
yeah which i like to point out and and
she's not just a catholic she's
she's a mel gibson's dad catholic
uh
this is
she's she's the catholics as you are to
atheists yes
she i mean this is like a court that
looks like the da vinci code now
so we thought it would be a good time to
do one of our favorite bits 24 things
you don't know about
amy connie barrett 24 things
24 not 25 they stole that from us all
right like
for example when my family play scrabble
we take out the letters lgbtq
the things you don't know about amy
comey about i won't eat chinese food
because fortune cookies look like
vaginas yeah that that sounds like her
[Applause]
when i'm stressed out i'll eat a whole
box of eucharist
thank you i'm a classically trained liar
my volleyball team was ten and three
against the other cults in our division
[Applause]
i believe the spanish inquisition had
fine people on both sides
in college i refuse the title magna
laude because it sounds dirty
and i'm looking forward to getting some
real hands-on experience being a judge
you